foreign
people don't believe me I'm like listen
guys Arizona is different everyone has a
gun I mean I was selling ashes in the
sixth grade in Arizona wow
a [ __ ] put a pinky nail out and had me
hit crystal meth in class in seventh
grade in class in Chandler I thought it
was coke it was [ __ ] Crystal yeah
Arizona's Turnt Up
she was such a pretty [ __ ] she had long
ass curly hair big ass earrings yeah
Julie she's a cartel baby for show she
had this long-ass Nails hey look at this
take a little bump on my I'm like oh
[ __ ] I started filling out my oh [ __ ]
what was that this [ __ ] burned so I got
that was Matt I'm like oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] I was on one for two days I was
[ __ ] up dude it was [ __ ] up did you
ever go through like uh you know
obviously outside of just experimenting
with drugs you ever go through like a
time where you were like doing coke on a
regular basis I was cooking for a while
yeah what years were that was that I was
bartending bro yeah because I said I did
it all do when I was eight 18 like 18 to
like 20 21 or 23 I was just your wallet
doing coke right doing some ex Molly now
Molly just Coke because Friday night was
Friday night was Hip Hop
Saturday night was techno and then
Sunday night was Salsa and all the
[ __ ] Cubans and Colombians would come
and they all found out I was only 18 19
right I was [ __ ] all the [ __ ] oh
man they kept giving me bumps key shots
give me like eight balls while I was
working it was just part of the culture
and the bartender lifestyle is very
shady very dirty lifestyle just coke
coke coke liquor and I was finally one
day I was like I can't do this
I almost OD'd that reggae in the river
that's what it was oh [ __ ] that's why I
stopped doing coke
Reagan the river what is that it's a
festival in Northern California where
it's on the river it's hot as hell I was
on coke and graters Gray Goose for three
days I turned pale and I dropped and I
woke up at the Medics and I go dude you
gotta you gotta just chill it out a
little bit and I remember I went home to
my chick's house and I did a bump and my
heart started doing the same thing it
did when I fainted I was like all right
that's it I'm done I don't want to die
that was it it's over I was about to
have a baby too so
it was rap yeah never never and that's
why I don't drink to this day though
because and that's why I don't drink
because when I drink it the combination
of cocaine and alcohol yeah it's a great
one
I've never done cocaine but I know that
the people who I know who I'm still
close with that's their thing is they
get drunk and they do Coke yeah because
you could just keep going yeah but I'm
glad I stopped that [ __ ] hella it's been
what uh Janelle's 14. it's been 15 years
since I touched that or alcohol wait so
you haven't drank in 15 years I've maybe
had like a couple sips or maybe with
whiz I took like one or two shots but I
don't drink drink no I don't know yeah
no yeah no you're right because I've
seen you like at Dre's and like you're
just I'm just there smoking yeah